[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission spécial
photo et quand on dit spécial photo sur
cette chaîne on dit Claude chose bonjour
Claude bonjour ça va bien ça va très
bien alors comme d'habitude vous êtes
venu nous présenter un photographe et un
invité exceptionnel oui exactement qui
est là Jacques de Givri jacqu de Givri
bonjour qui qui qui habite aux loges et
qui est un un homme un photographe
éditeur on va dire absolument ou qui a
fait beaucoup de livres vous avez vous
avez eu deux vies en fait vous êtes
ingénieur oui je suis ingénieur enfin
j'ai eu trois vies en fait trois oui
c'est beaucoup mais c'est c'est plus que
de la schizophrénie donc oui je suis
ingénieur électronicien de formation
j'ai eu mon diplôme en
1964 donc ça remonte un peu et attendez
j'ai j'ai lu le IFI la IFI c'est vous
oui c'est vous qui avez enventé pas le
Wii non la ifii pas wiii non j'ai j'ai
simplement été le premier fité qu le
premier à faire une chaîne haute
fidélité entièrement transhistorisée
d'accord donc ça a été de de
l'électronique analogique maintenant on
fait du numérique moi j'ai appris
l'analogique donc est déjà passé ah oui
oui évidemment non il eu des il y a des
des changements de pu mais mais c'est
quand même c'est quand même une une
invention extraordinaire ah ben c'était
un début d'une passion d'une autre
passion la passion du métier et en tant
que électronicien j'ai été amené à à
gérer pendant 33 ans chez Matra qui
s'appelait Matra espace à l'époque et
qui maintenant s'appelle Airbus defense
and space c'est et dans ce milieulà qui
était c'était les 30 glorieuses du
spatial j'ai eu l'occasion justement
d'avoir une vie passionnante sur le plan
purement
professionnel ça c'est donc la première
vie attendez parce qu'il a dit trois
viesoui alors la deuxième ben c'est la
photographie mais là j'ai commencé à 13
ans et demi j'ai fait ma première photo
à 13 ans et demi et j'ai fait une une
nature morte qui m'a donné 1 heure de
travail à 13 ans et3 c'est beaucoup et
ça déclenchait un petit peu toute la
suite
avec donc un travail photographique qui
s'est échelonné sur un certain nombre
d'années avant que je rentre dans le
domaine de l'édition photo et de d'une
carrière je dirais
d'éditeur et puis la troisème vie bien
c'est la vie associative que je mène
depuis ma retraite en 2000 et où la
photographie m'a entraîné c'est la
photographie en fait qu' a eu une
incidence importante sur la vie
associative parce qu'on me demandait des
photos sur la région de Versailles
c'était des associations de défense de
l'environnement principalement et euh
dans le
métier professionnel aussi la
photographie m'a été très utile pour
présenter faire des présentations
convaincante quand il avait une idée
d'invention une chose comme ça pouvoir
montrer photographiquement quelque chose
d'impeccable ça entraînit sentraîit
l'adhésion très régulièrement donc c'est
l'outil photographique est pour moi un
moyen d'expression et là vous êtes en
train de me demander de parler et je
montre pas une photo mais mais pardon
juste puisque vous parlez d'associatif
vous êtes président de de l'association
des amis de Versailles grandp alors
c'est je suis président oui de de
l'Association des Amis du grand parc de
Versailles le grand parc de Versailles
n'étant pas celui qu'on croit mais celui
qui exista du temps de lu 14 et qui
était plus grand que Paris on verra je
crois une image tout à l'heure sur le
sujet donc c'est un territoire qui
recouvre plusieurs communes donc Guill
encour où nous sommes par exemple c'est
partie du grand parc de chasse de Louis
X chass et cette association bien pour
mission de mettre en valeur le
patrimoine et de sauvegarder
l'environnement c'est à la fois
environnement et patrimoine ce qui est
assez rare Claude par mais je voudrais
te poser une vous poser une question
Jacques lai c'est parce que vous étiez
pass passionné par la musique aussi ah
j'étais passionné de musique classique
et de jazz quand j'étais gamin et j'ai
ça m'a conduit à faire des développer
des systèmes divers et variés de
haut-parleur deenceinte acoustique et
donc et puis après ça a été les
télécommandes je me suis passionné pour
les télécommandes tout ça de de
différents engins y compris des engins
balistiques après chez Matra et est-ce
que est-ce que
votre savoir d'ingénieur a influencé
votre travail de photographe absolument
parce que quand on a un travail enfin
une responsabilité de projet dans
l'industrie on garde cet esprit là quand
on fait un projet de livre faire un
projet de livre c'est un véritable
projet d'ingénieur à la limite et on
peut devenir directeur éditorial sans
savoir qu'on est aussi un peu ingénieur
mais il faut structurer toute la
l'opération parce que faire des belles
photos c'est une chose mais après il
faut faire le livre c'est aussi
apprendre tout un métier et ensuite il
faut le commercialiser et quand vous
avez à chaque livre 4000 ou 5000
exemplaires ça se part ça part pas comme
ça ou surtout maintenant mais même dans
il y a 40 ans c'était déjà un peu
difficile mais beaucoup plus facile que
mainten plus qu'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
ça se le livre se vend un peu moins il
se il s'en fait beaucoup toujours mais
ils se vendent pas beaucoup les tirages
de
photograp d'album photographique sont
plutôt de l'ordre de 1000 2000
exemplaires al que je faisais du 5000
exempla VO plus c'est un N plus facile
de alors le le travail de Jacques Claude
alors moi je connais Jacques depuis euh
pas mal d'années c'est un travail sur
Versailles il a fait beaucoup de choses
sur Versailles mais pas que Versailles
tout son environnement toute
effectivement comme Jacques vient de
parler de de de du grand parc de
Versailles qui était aussi grand que
Paris donc en plus c'était on parle de
9000 hectares donc voilà et quand on
passe d'ailleurs la la l'image qui mon
actuellement c'est le premier livre
c'était par les champs et par les
greffes de bellî en mer j'ai presque
toujours fait oui j'ai une maison là-bas
donc ça ça aide un petit peu mais je
vais là-bas depuis 40 ans et j'ai
commencé donc mon premier ouvrage mon
premier désir ça a été de faire un livre
sur Bell n'existait pas et tous les
livres que j'ai fait ensuite c'était en
général sur des sujet qui n'avaient pas
été traité le Potager du Roi à
Versailles il y avait pas de livre euh
le jardin du lu ambourg il y avait pas
de livre et cetera je peux vous en citer
comme ça jardin albercan à Boulogne tout
ça il n'existait aucun livre et donc
j'ai toujours fait ce choix et là voilà
une quinzaine d'ouvrages qui sont
montrés voilà dont certains ont été des
livre compliqué euh par exemple celui
sur Varangeville on verra je pense
quelques photos aussi c'était très
ambitieux un un coffret avec deux livres
toilés et cetera c'était une une
opération sont pas des commandes he
c'est c'est non non c'était à chaque
fois une prise de passion pour un sujet
pour un thème pour un village pour un
paysage
pour avec peu de personnages à part le
jardin Luxembourg alors là je mets que
des personnes mais voilà par exemple
barangeville un exemple de de lieu qui
m'a tout à fait
passionné et je me suis rendu compès
loin de di c'est ça on est pas loin de
DIP Pourville et là vous voyez le petit
cimetière qui se trouve au pied de
l'église il va passer un jour dans
quelqu la falaise recule de 50 cm ch
année et chaque année la tombe de Brac
la tombe de Brac qui est dans ce
cimetière un jour partira à la mer dans
l'eau va monter dans un siècle un siècle
et demi ça danger déjà des maisons qui
tombent j'ai une amie qui m'a à qui j'ai
envoyé ta photo parce que elle a une
location elle va dans cette dans ce
village et effectivement elle m'a fait
découvrir l'intégralité de ton livre je
propose à T t spectateurs de faire un
petit tour rapide à Varangeville c'est
le plus joli coin entre dunkererque et
Le Havre c'est là l'endroit vraiment qui
surprend extraordinairement j' fait un
village de 1000 habitants j'ai fait 5000
exemplaires du livre du coffret je n'en
ai plus à vendre vous n'avez plus à
vendre voilà non si on veut se procurer
des livres on peut quand même alors oui
c'est maintenant j'ai encore quelques
livres qui se vendent au château de
Versailles et dans certaines chez Gibert
à versaill des choses comme ça un peu
par la Fnac mais c'est quand même limité
maintenant parce que je suis un suis
plus tout à fait un jeune photographe
j'ai 84 ans,8 je ti la précis V propou
on commence à compter derrière la
virgule alors moi j'ai découvert Jacques
parce que je m'intéresse beaucoup au
château de Versailles aussi à son
environnement et j'ai un ami qui m'a
parlé du réseau hydraulique et il m'a
dit j'ai un bouquin sur le réseau
hydraulique de ver qui est absolument
superbe et c'est comme ça que j'ai j'ai
acheté le livre je l'ai sur les grandes
eau sur les grandes eau et où il
explique tout ce
réseau on voit sous le château enfin
sous le parter d'eau derrière le château
là vous avez des bassins souterrain qui
sont absolument magnifiques je paris que
Louis XIV n'est jamais venu voir ce qui
se passait une fois que c'était fini
parce qu'il fallait descendre par un
trou d'homme c'est pas très royal mais
il y avait là une architecture
magnifique et je suis un peu amoureux de
la
statuaire de versaill et j'ai là aussi
fait plusieurs livres sur le domaine et
en particulier des photos de nuit un
livre nu alors j'ai vu des livres qui
ont été traduit en anglais en allemand
aussi voilà un exemple de photo un petit
peu délicate à prendre puisquil faut
aller à 10 km pour prendre cette photo
donc c'est depuis l'aérodrome de
chavenet j'avais étudié les carart je me
dis c'est le seul endroit
doit voire la du château tout son
déploiement et là k que là on voit la
grandeur du et moi j'ai trouvé cette
photo extraordinaire si tu
ve alors c'est les photos de nuit très
épurées comme ça c'est c'est évidemment
un bonheur quand on arrive à voir ça
dans son objectif il faut le chercher ai
déplié un
peu je voudrais que Jacques nous
explique parce que on dit que les
fontaines représentent la flor de Liss
et quand on voit ça la photo de Jacques
là on voit vraiment la fleur de Liss et
voilà oui c'est moi-même je ne le savais
pas que ça représentait la fleur de Liss
ce GDO et la nuit j'ai fait tout un
livre donc sur la nuit à
versa et ferry des jardins il s'appelle
cette image là justement m'a fait
apparaître la fleur de lis comme jamais
il y a un peu de pause de je sais pas 3
4 secondes ou 5 secondes qui a lissé
l'image et qui donne un résultat
effectivement très évocateur de la fleur
de Liss et il y a beaucoup de symboles à
Versailles en voilà un qui a révélé vous
vous a quand vous faites ce genre de
travail Vous demandez des autorisations
les j'ai eu des autorisations parfois
mais à peu près le 10e du temps à
versaill ça a été ça mais
habituellement je je me promène en
touriste normal mais j'ai eu que j'ai
fait un livre avec Pierre-André lablude
qui
était l'architecte en chef en CH des
jardins ça c'est le théâtre avec
les Marie Antoinette qui est magnifique
et avec le oui ça c'est quand mon
absolument oui donc j'ai fait un gros
travail sur Trianon le Petit Trianon
j'ai faire un livre total je l'ai pas
fait pour le moment mais ça pourraitir
alors parce que il existe en version
numérique mais il n'existe pas en
version offset tirage et voilà donner un
peu de vie à la statuire de versaill
c'est aussi un but pour photographe
c'est non pas de prendre plein pot une
image bien verticale mais de saisir les
détails le rimouleur euh qui représente
Brutus je crois l'assassin de César euh
avec son couteau qu'il est en train
d'affuter mais il a une suur d'angoisse
à l'idée qu'il va tuer son son père son
père on voit bien que Jacques il mène la
connaissance aussi de de
l'histoirehistoire avec la modernité de
il faut apprendre à devenir un peu
historien quand on fait ce genre de
travaou qu mieux euh il faut faire un
travail sérieux et je m'entoure d'expert
d'ailleurs pour faire pour les textes
parfois je fais le texte moi-même mais
parfois c'est par exemple avec
Pierre-André Lablaude c'est l'auteur du
texte un grand expert du du sujet d'cord
et puis moi ben je fais les photos et
parfois je fais le livre entièrement je
je l'édite j'ai fait à peu près je sais
pas 35 livres dont une douzaine ont été
édité par d'autres éditeurs et les
autres et les autres je suis auteur
éditeur c'est de
l'autoédition avec deux collections une
qui
s'appelle l'esprit des lieux petit
format enfin 22 22 22 et puis une autre
collection Mémoire et lumière qui est
plus ambitieuse plus de pages et 24 300
enfin grand livre voilà mais à chaque
fois que je commande un livre qu'ils
arrivent les palettes arrivent sur un
camion et j'ai environ 8 tonnes de
livres qui arrivent dans mon garage
distribuer après il faut les distribuer
j'ai eu une épouse qui m'a beaucoup aidé
qui a
poussé oui c'est que vous avez raison de
dire que c'est un autre une troisème vie
parce que c'est un autre mé une vie de
commerce malheureusement qu'il faut
assumer aussi sinon sinon ça ça reste
dans sa cave ouis bien sûr et on avait
reçu nous avions reçu Patrice vous vous
souvenez Francis tac avec son livre sur
Buc
et était aussi sur le système et Jacques
avait épaulé notre ami Françis ou oui je
l'avais introduit dans le monde de
l'édition c'estàd chez moi en faisant
des livres sur la vallée de la a eu de
livres qui ét fait avec Francis donc
voilà c'est un travail remarquable hein
oui moi je trouve c'est pour ça que j'ai
j'ai tenu à invité Jacques à à notre
émission quand même les livres que vous
avez vousmême édité il il y a pas un
site où on peut si j'ai un site qui
s'appelle
www.jdg publication jdz
c'est JDG publication avec un s au
pluriel et com et avec ça on trouve tous
mes livres sont indiqués sur alors
beaucoup sont épuisés ou je peux les
donner à consulter je peux donner un un
DVD un CD qui permet de de garder la
mémoire j'ai fait pas mal d'expositions
une soixantaine d'expositions dont
certaines un peu ambitieuse comme celle
qui était là à viltin il y a quelques
années euh sur le plateau de donc tout
une expo avec des photographes invités
là vous avez j'habite au log Josas ben
voilà un dernier vestige en bon état de
des portes du grand parc qui avait 24
portes dessinées par Ardouin MONSARD qui
ces portes là bon il y en a plus que six
maintenant en à peu près visible il y en
a une sur
Saint-Quentin et puis voilà c'est celle
du loge quoi plus précisément il y en a
une sur la route quand tu longes la
route entre Châteaufort et voisin
Bretonneux qui est à l'intérieur du parc
national et et qui a été restauré pour
être montrable voilà le les ét l'ts
vieux de sa
clé on peut photographier les temps mais
aussi un peu les brins d'herbes qui sont
là ça peut donner une lumière ça c'est
sa clé hein
c'est je pense que la question
que dans le cadre de cette émission je
je serais intéressé pour que Jacques
nous nous parle de du projet qu'il a
c'est de de restituer les perspective
faite par le nôtre pour le château il y
en a une qui est derrière comme disait
Jacques le château qui amène vers
Villepreux qui va jusqu'à Villepreux si
je mes souvenir son je vais laisser la
parole à Jacques qui va bien nous
l'expliquer oui donc le nôtre a réalisé
pour Louis XIV la grande perspective de
Versailles c'est son che chef-dœuvre un
peu
ignoré jusqu'à nos jours jusqu'à ce que
mon association des Amis du grand parc
en 2000 réveille un peu tout le monde
sur le sujet et disent mais voyons on a
12 km 500 de perspective la plus
majestueuse d'Europe jamais faite
peut-être du monde 9 17 m de large qui
allait de véisie jusqu'à Villepreux en
passant par virireoflet Versailles
saint-sy Fontain fleur re moulin et
cette perspective on a fait la promotion
dans les années au début des années 2000
j'ai fait un livre en 2004 qui a montré
toute cette historique et la communauté
d'agglomération Versailles Grand Parc a
repris le flambeau elle s'est d'ailleurs
appelé Versailles Grand par de de notre
fête d'accord et elle s'est chargée de
restaurer toute la partie qui va jusqu'à
villeprux maintenant je me bats pour que
côté est on finisse la même chose la
même chose dans la forêt de de
Versailles forêt de Manal de versaill
c'est essentiellement surv reflet et
j'espère que dans quelques temps on
verra je sais pas si on peut le montrer
une donnez-moi pe-être vous verrez mieux
comme ça est-ce que on peut zoomer là
c'est peut-être pas facile zoomer c'est
pas facile ou oui une tour en bois qui
sera un belvedire permettant ah de voir
de voir tout versaill pile en face du
château et n on verra la Tour Effel le
sacré cœur la défense tout ça
sera vu depuis l' haut donc pour les
Jeux Olympiques il y aura peut-être une
surprise non pas de la Tour définitive
mais d'une
tour
provisoire tout ça en lien avec l'ONF
ben merci merci infiniment des c'est
travail formidable euh quelques mots
peut-être Claude sur des expos
encore actuellement il y a des
expositions à voir qui sont en phase
terminale je dire puce que on passe
d'une période 2023 2024 il y a entre
autres à la Galerie Polka euh rue
Saint-Gilles à Paris donc pas très loin
de la place des Voges il y a une
exposition où on peut voir les images de
Steve macury en couleur
euh clin donc qui montre aussi des
photos sur sur Paris en noir et blanc et
aussi un très beau travail sur de de
Monsieur Ribou Marc Ribou donc sur son
travail qu'il a fait à la suite de il
avait rencontré quartier Bresson qui l'
euh dans lequel il a pas suivi mais
Cartier breesson lui a lui a insufflé
l'amour de l'Asie où il on présente il
présente tout un tas d'images sur l'Asie
quiil a fait à cette périodelà il y a
aussi une une une exposition euh à
comment s'appelle au jeu de pomes à
Paris donc de Madame juliaen margarette
Cameron sur capturer la beauté donc
jusqu'au 28 janvier c'est pour ça que je
j'en parle fa faire très vite parce que
c'est c'est demain et puis bien sûr il y
a ACCP à corord à s'appelleou vous déjà
conseillé voilà c'est ça et qui est très
intéressante puisqueelle elle dure donc
jusqu'au 25 euh au au 25 mars et puis on
va démarrer maintenant une nouvelle
période et lors de la prochaine émission
Patrice je vous propose qu'on puisse
parler de ce qui va se passer donc sur
les mois de février mars av en mars il y
a un certain clre chose qui fait une
expos exactement je vous remercie de
rappeler ça sur les bouinistes les
bouquinistes vous savez que c'est un
alure actuel ils sont on en parle
beaucoup il y a beaucoup de choses qui
se disent on dit que on veut supprimer
les cases non on veut pas les supprimer
on veut les enlever pour permettre le
regard sur la scène lors du défilé des
des des sélections de Cha pay
mais après il aème est-ce qu'on va
remettre les mêmes voilà il voudrait
qu'on remette les mêmes mais il y a des
gens qui ont des idées on va en reparler
avant l'exposition qui qui a lieu au
mois de mars et puis on va remercier
Jacques deivr surtout c'est moi qui vous
remercie de cette invitation d'être ven
et on rappelle JDG publication JDG
publication pluri mais moi j'ai vu le il
y a une image que Jacques a fait que
j'aime beaucoup c'est celle du Petit
Théâtre de Marie-Antoine ou mag on l' vu
tout à l'heure on on l'a vu ben d'abord
c'est un lieu c'est un lieu sublime
extraordinaire peu de G connaissent et
tout ça c'est un carton pâ con un papier
mâché et on a on a l'impression qu'on
rentre presque dans l'opé a trois décors
enfin qu'on change comme ça quand on
veut enfin c'est c'est absolument
formidable mais ça ça se visite par
petit groupe c'est beaucoup de le
visiteroui absolument merci infiniment
merci beaucoup claud chose je vous
remercie Patrice de de votre accueil je
remercie aussi Jacques
d'être venre c'est et d'avoir
j'ai travaillé avec Jacques pour essayer
de faire une une
présentation donc je l'ai un peu je l'ai
un peu torturé torturé mais non il sort
bien de la torture donc voilà merci
beaucoupci beaucoup à très bientôt pour
une autre émission sur la photo et à
très
[Musique]
bientôt